[Music]
we've done hands that have webs in
between them horns Spike's lizard feet
Viking boots whiskers teeth there is no
mascot handbook and if there is there
shouldn't be my name is Brittany and I
make mascots olympos group was done in
1893 it's located in beautiful North
Milwaukee Wisconsin
each mascot is different it's such an
art form it definitely takes a lot of
passion takes a lot of creativity takes
a lot of teamwork and the people who
work here are absolutely amazing and
what they can do there's Molly she's the
head fabrication technician Steve he's
the sketch in sculpting artists Sally is
the engineering and the pre-press
specialist Mary is the foam fabrication
technician and Alyssa is the patterning
and sewing lead and then there's
Mitchell he usually delivers us lunch
[Music]
whenever we get a request in and we get
around a table and we come up for the
plan the request can be anything from a
detailed presentation to a doodle on a
cocktail napkin the sketch team will
sketch up a rendering for the customer
and then we'll send that out for
approvals after that settled wheat lunch
is very important we have tight
deadlines we can't always get out and
sit down at lunch so sometimes it's
really helpful to be able to get
delivery to help us through our day
collaboration is super important there's
no one person can make a whole costume
first it will go to the sculptor who
sculpts the head we'll turn that into a
mold the mold will then be vacuform it's
kind of like something out of a sci-fi
movie it's a lot of fun to watch once
the heads are vacuform did all put
together then they go over to our
technicians on our head covering team
they'll pull fabrics from the wall and
begin gluing the fabric onto the head
and then it's a matter of cutting fabric
sewing it together adding kind of those
last finishing details to get the whole
costume to come together to fit as one
piece
and we'll make sure it's able to meet
all the necessary requirements the
performer will need job as soon as you
put that head on crack the person kind
of like becomes that character dance
some people will start to dance and do
poses they can be kind of
larger-than-life and then we'll do a
photo shoot it is just very cool to kind
of see the whole process all coming
together and being finished there's a
ton of pride when it comes to that
moment once the mascot is complete we'll
go to wherever the next cocktail napkin
takes us